[Musique]
bienvenue pour ce nouveau numéro 2 si on
rentrait avant derniers de ce mois de
décembre au cours duquel nous
reviendrons sur noël qui approchent et à
la commanderie d'elancourt une série
d'animations et d'ateliers autour de ce
thème est proposé tout au long de la
semaine mais aussi ce week end des
rendez-vous 100% virtuel vous n'avez pas
encore décorer votre sapin nous sommes
allés prendre quelques conseils auprès
des fermes de gally à saint cyr l'école
et puis nous quitterons l'ambiance des
fêtes de fin d'année pour se plonger
dans la vidéothèque de l'association
yvelinoise contrechamp à redécouvrir
cette semaine millénium actrice film
japonais de à 2002 au cours de ce numéro
2 si on rentrait nous parlerons aussi
musique avec l artiste sommeil et le
collectif very green à la verrière qui
nous montrera comment réaliser son
propre dentifrice bonjour célia avec
vous nous allons donc voir comment
décorer son sapin pour noël
il faut faire preuve de créativité oui
alors je me suis rendu donc aux fermes
de gally à à saint-cyr-l'ecole un là-bas
en chalets de noël a été construit pour
l'occasion avec énormément de décoration
pour votre sapin et votre intérieur
alors pour décorer ce fameux arbre de
noël il y a quatre étapes et la première
c'est la guirlande électrique commence
généralement par le bas
de telle sorte que la rallonge ce soit
pratique à brancher sur le secteur sur
la prise électrique et on va monter la
guirlande électrique dit qui sans
hésiter à rentrer à l'intérieur du sapin
si on arrive à la fin de la guirlande au
milieu du sapin c'est pas un souci on va
intégrer une seconde guirlandes en
faisant tomber la rallonge au centre du
sapin pour qu'elle aille en bas et puis
on va continuer d'installer la guirlande
à l'intérieur et en périphérie du sapin
ça va je me débrouille pas trop mal
quand j'entends ces conseils est ce
qu'il ya des couleurs aussi à
privilégier
oui oui il y a des couleurs la tendance
cette année c'est le retour au
traditionnel avec eux du rouge associé à
du blanc et du bois mais les trois
couleurs phare reste toujours le rouge
le vert et le doré donc là il ya plein
de branchages
plein de points de fleurs de branches de
coton le troisième élément qu'on va
positionner ça va être tout les petite
guirlande de perles qui vont en iran en
périphérie du sapin et on finit par les
boules de telle sorte qu'elles soient
passionnés sur le devant et qu'elle soit
ou bien visible lumière avec lumière mis
en examen points avec célia en direct si
vous nous suivez à 18 heures j'étais un
peu vite en besogne parce que une fois
la lumière installé et encore d'autres
choses à faire
oui c'est ça dont on parlait donc de
lumière mais aussi les éléments donc à
tiquer aussi et puis bien sûr les
tendances de l'année c'est ces trois
couleurs là aussi sur ses couverts laon
où on est sûr de pas se tromper parce
que c'est vraiment l'un des marqueurs
forts de noël et puis après on a des
des univers qui sont assez froids blanc
et bleu qui sont aussi très sympathique
mais qui sont moins chaleureux que le
rouge ou d'auray
et jusqu'à quand garder son sapin c'est
toujours la grande question
oui ben alors finalement jusqu'au 25
décembre minimum après souvent on garde
son sapin jusqu'au 1er janvier mais film
a finalement il n'y a pas de règle
chacun fait comme il veut merci beaucoup
coeliakie bonne décoration à vous on
reste dans l'esprit et de noël avec les
ateliers de la commanderie des longs
cours l'équipement culturel de saint
quentin en yvelines propose cette année
un hymne aux ailes décalé comme les
années passées des ateliers des
animations sont proposées mais 100%
virtuel la commanderie revient avec son
eee noël décalé une programmation 100%
ligne cette année avec marché de noël
virtuel lectures musicales ou encore
ateliers le public nous manque que les
artistes où manquent les intervenants
nous manque et du coup on avait envie de
ne pas rester deux mois sans rien
proposer à la commanderie et de faire ce
lien jusqu'à la fin de l'année en
espérant des jours meilleurs mois de
janvier les ateliers sont accessibles à
tous et variées au programme fabrication
de lanternes de produits cosmétiques et
réalisation de recettes de cuisine et de
cartes de noël ou encore yoga du rire
les ateliers pour les enfants des études
pour les adultes parce qu'on a envie eu
envie de concerner tous les publics
et donc voilà il suffit de s'inscrire de
choisir un ou des ateliers pour certains
ateliers le public vient chercher des
kits puisqu'on leur a préparé tout le
matériel pour pouvoir réaliser leur
fabrication en même temps que
l'intervenant en direct dit connexion au
maximum sont possibles par atelier une
fois inscrit un mémo est envoyé aux
participants indiquant leur ait un lien
pour se connecter
on se retrouve ensemble en visio comme
on a appris à le faire depuis quelques
mois tous en visio voilà on a tout
organisé pour pour pouvoir les
accueillir
virtuellement la commanderie d'autres
ateliers auront lieu ce week end
fabrication de mangeoires à oiseaux ou
encore emballage cadeau il encore
possible de s'y inscrire programme et
réservations sur le site de la
commanderie
[Musique]
en début d'émission nouveau expliquions
comment décorer son sapin de noël
à présent nous allons réaliser notre
propre dentifrice bonjour astrid devons
jouer le fruit d' un oui effectivement
je suis allé chez valérie klein de
l'association very green à leur
présenter ses recettes de dentifrice et
vous allez voir c'est très simple je
vais commencer par mettre 30 g de blanc
de meudon dans un pot en verre qui a été
stérilisés ça c'est important quand on
fait des cosmétiques à la maison d'abord
on stérilise toujours ces petits pots
ses ustensiles
alors ensuite à ses 30 grammes il faut
ajouter 5 gouttes d'huile essentielle
ça peut être de là - de poivre et du
citron ou même du titre i qui lui est
ainsi antiseptiques et la recette est
finie déjà on pourrait mais on peut
aussi ajouter des propriétés au
dentifrice
on a tout un tas de propriété qu'on
trouve dans notamment dans les plantes
et des plantes
en fait on en a partout et elles sont
pleines de propriété donc c'est vraiment
très intéressant notamment
donc on a le thym et le romarin qui sont
des plantes antiseptique
antibactériennes alors il ya aussi la
sauge qui a un côté désinfectants et
cicatrisant le plantain ou encore lortie
qui elle est bien connue pour ses
vitamine c vitamine et son côté
minéralisant on peut faire un mix donc
de toutes ces plantes qu'on réduit en
poudre et donc ajouter 10 grammes de
cette poudre à la préparation on ajoute
un tout petit peu de bicarbonate de
soude sur une pointe de couteau par
exemple parce que ça permet de salive et
à ce niveau là votre recette de
dentifrice à les terminer
c'est à dire que vous prenez votre
brosse à dents vous trempez votre brosse
dans l'eau et vous là vous l'appliquez
comme ça sur
la brosse à dents vous brosser les dents
avec ça alors valérie conseils pour
permettre une transition plus facile
entre le dentifrice du commerce et les
dentifrices maison d'ajouter encore deux
ingrédients pour avoir un effet un peu
plus pâteux comme on al'habitude de la
glycérine végétale bio c'est très
important et un peu d'eau pour la
glycérine
il faut pas dépasser 10% du grammage de
l'après de la préparation
donc si on a 40 g de préparation il faut
ajouter entre 3 et 4 % des lycéens enfin
un peu de mathématiques un pont pas se
tromper bien sûr merci beaucoup à ce
raid et pour ceux qui veulent revoir
aussi votre chronique sur comment
réaliser sa lessive maison rendez vous
sur notre site internet rubrique ripley
dans les archives de si on rentrait et
c'était également avec l'association
very green qu'on remercie contrechamp
associations de programmation et
d'éducation à l'image dans les yvelines
nous invite à présent à redécouvrir l'un
des chefs-d'oeuvre à de l'animation à
japonaise c'est notre page septième art
aujourd'hui on a eu envie de vous
présenter un film qui était une
véritable célébration du cinéma ce film
c'est millenium actress film d'animation
japonais réalisé par satoshi kon en 2001
millénium actrice cette actrice
millénaire c'est celle yoko fujiwara
inquiète une actrice de fiction une
actrice de l'âge d'or des studios
japonais et cette actrice personnage
principal du film est retirée isolé dans
sa maison depuis près de 30 ans elle va
accepter la visite et la demande
d'interview d'un journaliste qui
accompagnait de son de son caméraman va
assister au récit de la vie
en même temps que le spectateur de la
vie de cette actrice
le film est une plongée vertigineuse et
époustouflante visuellement dans
l'histoire du cinéma et du cinéma
japonais
la vie de cette actrice mail à tous les
rôles qu'elle a interprété dans tous ses
films le réalisateur satoshi kon
brouille la frontière entre fiction et
réalité
c'est vraiment une oeuvre qui méritent
d'être découvertes ou redécouvertes
connus et reconnus et nous passons du
cinéma à la musique avec vous justin
bonjour l'artiste yvelinois sommeil et
je vais bien prononcé a sorti son
nouveau single ce vendredi 4 décembre gm
au coeur c'est un titre qui fait écho à
la crise sanitaire actuelle qui
racontent ce que vivent les plus jeunes
les commerçants tous ces acteurs aussi
considéré comme non essentielles
pourquoi at il choisi ce thème
et bien tout simplement pas parler de la
crise sanitaire pour faire comprendre un
peu la colère mais de manière douce
puisque sommeil en tant qu'artiste fait
partie des personnes qui se sont sentis
oubliés et donc il a voulu parler de
cette crise tout simplement pour montrer
qu'elle n'a épargné personne et je vous
propose d'ailleurs de regarder un
extrait de gémo coeur dans le kit
sortait aujourd'hui génération mise à la
main
génération qui va payer 135 raison
d'être tendre
mais tu préfères noah meynier
la crise est violente et le tue
elle est plus tous à l'elysée
marche pas dans nos chaussures ne
dorment pas sur le pape est incroyable
son but avec gym au coeur c'est
d'encourager chacune et chacun à agir
pour ne plus subir à cette crise
c'est vraiment un appel à tous les
secteurs où didier appliquez-le
personnes se sont donc dit aussi de se
réveiller et de devenir acteur de cette
fille et non plus la subir et ce nom de
g moqueur mockingbird il vient d'où bien
compris donc c'est un oiseau un qui qui
est dans le film qui symbolise la
rébellion justement dans hunger games
est donc c'est un symbole qui l'a
inspiré ici son message c'est qu'on est
tous moteurs de cette crise sanitaire et
qu'il faut pas absorber les informations
sans les comprendre
même si j'appelle à à comprendre cette
épidémie
il faut faire des gestes il faut pas
faire des gestes sans raison et il faut
il faut être acteur et comprendre les
choses et ne pas se laisser dicter les
choses et donc là son single vient de
sortir un album est en préparation aussi
exactement et sortira il sera composé de
10 titres
il sortira au printemps 2021 et puis il
faut savoir qu'il a lancée sur une plate
forme dont cumule une campagne de
crowdfunding pour pour financer tout ça
et puis il est déjà à plus de 90% de son
objectif quand même
donc s'ils voulaient participer il ya le
lien qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
ulule.com etc sommeil pour le nom de
l'artiste
merci justin mais merci à vous d'avoir
suivi ce si on rentre est peut-être l'un
des derniers on l'espère c'est
finalement mi-janvier maintenant avec
les dernières annonces qui ont été
faites et nous pourrons de nouveau
retrouvé le chemin des salles de
spectacle et un peu plus de liberté en
attendant protégez vous protéger les
autres et à très bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]